from the perspective of money do you
have hope that cryptocurrency can help
resist war can help
resist the negative effects of
authoritarian regimes
or is that a silly hope
wars
happen
because the people
who have the power to command armed
forces
miscalculate
that's generally what happens
and we will have a big war in the near
future if
both the chinese government and the us
government miscalculates
and they unleash lethal lethal force on
one another and there's nothing that any
financial institution can do to stop
that
any more than the rothschilds could
rothschilds could stop world war one
and they were then the biggest bank in
the world by far with massive
international financial influence
so let's accept that war is
is in a different domain
war
would impact the financial world
massively if it were a war between the
united states and china because
there's still a huge
china trade on
wall street is long china
europe is long china
so the conflict that i could foresee in
the future is one that's highly
financially disruptive
where does crypto fit in
crypto's obvious
utility in the short run
is as a store of
wealth of transferable wealth for people
who live
in dangerous places with
failing not just failing money but
failing rule of law
that's why in latin america there's so
much interest in crypto because latin
americans have a lot of monetary history
to look back on and not much of it is
good
so i think that the short run
problem that crypto solves
is and this goes back to the the digital
gold point
if you are in a dangerous place with
weak rule of law and weak property
rights
here is a new and better way
to have portable wealth
i think the next
question to ask is
would you want to be long crypto
in the event of world war iii
what's interesting about that question
is that world war iii would likely have
a significant cyber dimension to it
and i don't want to be a hundred percent
in crypto if
they crash the internet
which between them china and russia
might be able to do
that's a fascinating question whether
you want to be holding physical gold or
digital gold in the event of world war
three the smart person who studied
history definitely wants better both
and
so let's imagine world war iii has a
very very severe cyber component to it
with high levels of disruption
yeah you'd be glad of the old the old
shiny stuff
at that point
so
diversification still seems like the
most important
truth of a financial history yeah and
and what is crypto it's just this
wonderful new source of diversification
but you'd be nuts to be a 100 in bitcoin
i mean i i have some friends who are
probably quite close to that close to
100 i
admire the i'd mar the balls of steel
you